I have this weird hypothetical okay okay
and this was something I was I've been
thinking about all week because I've
been playing Final Fantasy 16. right oh
yeah right I knew you're gonna bring
that great [__] game right but one
thing I noticed while playing Final
Fantasy 16 right is that like so let's
explain to you oh no you've played the
demo right I've played four hours yeah
so you know that it's like kind of gone
back to the whole like medieval setting
yes right of like you know kind of the
renaissancey type of uh setting
um yeah just basically 16 hours
everyone's [__] British yeah they are
I love it but like one thing right that
I thought about while playing uh 16
right is that like when you go to like a
random Village and this is not just in
Final Fantasy this is like in any RPG
that's set in like the you know old
British setting right and you go to like
a random ass Village
and there's the village Elder right
who's like usually like pretty senile
you know like maybe like 70 80 sometimes
90 years old right
and I kept thinking to myself I'm like
where did that stereotype come from
she's like a national thing but was it
an actual yeah it was an actual thing
because like I find that hard to believe
because it's like wait why because
that's an old people existed no no that
I find that okay here's the reason why
so here's the question I had right
asking why is that one's old guy that is
the old guy yeah yeah because people
died
like no like living during those times
well it was obviously rare because the
average age was like [__] 40. yeah
like people still live till like 70.
pretty often you think so yeah I think
you just answered your own question
because you know of course if you live
to like especially you're like yo
especially in like you know maybe in a
village of 100 people yeah you know odds
are people would die I mean what age
what period are we talking of time like
let's say like let's go back to like
1300s yeah I mean odds up people weren't
like what was the app can you Google
what the average age yeah yeah
the average age was probably like 30.
oh yeah it was like 40. okay not much
but that was mainly because of like
child mortality as well right infant
mortality was huge yeah but even like
you know the whole like fact of like you
know the uh you know medical practices
weren't up to what they are now
obviously and like obviously
I mean it's like how you you sometimes
see old people now who will go to like
seven years old with zero like ever ever
going yeah everything yeah but that must
have been insane like if you were living
yeah the village
and there was like if you if you were in
the 1300 like dark ages in Europe and
you just went to a ran a village and you
saw like an 80 year old that's like the
equivalent to seeing like a 120 year
olds in it yeah no no no no I would
think well I mean it was it was like
rare but I mean it wasn't that rare but
it's like you know someone who had been
around who'd been in the position where
they had been in a lot of power who was
who was still alive yeah obviously they
would become someone who's respected
yeah I mean at that point everyone be
like I mean he's [__] alive he must
be doing something
why the Final Fantasy make you think of
this because I was just thinking about
it you have the average age
33 33 yeah it's it's also I mean every
they were having a war there was always
a war going on exactly just killing each
other so I was like how the [__] did the
older survive
[Music]
um well I mean there was I I mean I
don't [__] know I don't know the
exact answer but obvious people were
still that just because the average age
is is 33 doesn't mean people
couldn't get to no no no I I but it must
have been like incredibly rare yeah I
think you would be the village Elder
like 60 at that point yeah 55 yeah like
yeah you'd probably be the village Elder
yeah but in all video games they're
always like [__] 90 plus oh
they caught in like the modern view
right also they might just look their
way because they're British you know
yeah we also like well it's also like
it's like the concept of like why do
people look older in older media like
someone who's 16 in like an 80s film
looks like 25 to us yeah I think that is
a thing yeah yeah
watch a movie in the 80s yeah and
everyone in high school oh like sorry
well understood not a movie sorry like
look at a yearbook of like the 80s it's
a generic yearbook people will just look
old but even movies as well like if you
go back and watch like a James Dean
movie right like that dude died when he
was like what 23 24 something like that
but you look at it and you don't think
to yourself that that's a 20 year old in
that movie that's right he looks older
than I can believe he's 20 but he just
looks older to me for something I
remember Vsauce did a whole video yeah
yeah I just pulled up a yearbook from
1980s America yeah look how old these
people look
this is these are high school students
see they look like in their 20s yeah
they like yeah so you can look older
[__] yeah it's like why is that have you
ever seen your parents pictures when
they were younger yeah it's weird
do you ever get this thing where your
parents tell you a story about some [__]
they got up to when they're like they
were kids with your age and [__] and it
just doesn't seem real and just it
almost seems like they're like reciting
a movie or something when when like I
mean it's gonna be even worse for our
kids to be like so I was just online
meme harambe right you remember right
because here's the thing and I pulled my
dick out but here's like the difference
you know when when our kids get to our
age with the at least for us they're
gonna have like there's gonna be a
generation of kids that can see like
video and photo proof of all of the [__]
yeah and all the stupid [__] that their
parents got up to when they were like
their age but for me for Our Generation
we have like one or two photos that our
parents took at high school or something
like that and the rest is all anecdotal
yeah so when my aunt tells me huh you
know what your mom got up to when she
was 18 let me tell you what happened uh
I just like she won up this building it
was insane
some anti she got up to that there's one
bar and I'm just like that didn't happen
that's there's no [__] there there is no
way my mother did that you know there is
no way my mother my mother unhinged my
mother getting a blackout drunk no that
that doesn't happen and then you know
you hear these stories and it just like
it almost just doesn't feel real to you
because there's no like grounded
evidence to like like prove it in your
mind see it makes sense for your parents
because I look at your parents now and
they're like so well behaved and so like
you know on point when I hear my parents
talk about their like the [__] they got
up to when they were young I look at
them now and I'm like yeah I can see
that well there's gonna be on town I
mean their parents will never tell you
the really wild stuff they might have
done no of course not because they're
afraid probably they'd be like oh well
you know since I did it when I was young
then it gives you an excuse to win
you're young and I don't want my child
to do it
you have when you're like 40 they're
like really old and you'll be like all
right you're going soon tell me all the
[__] up [__]
you I've got four years left hops tell
me I I think I'm actually like slowly
starting to reach like that age though
because I've slowly been kind of like
being drip fed tea like here and there
from like various family members to be
like wait Auntie did what when she was
younger uh uncle was like this and yeah
it's it's slowly getting to that point
for me at least I don't think I've I
don't think I have the entire teacup I
have like a little there are a few few
little drops of tea of like crumbs yeah
a few little crumbs of tea of like
what's uh what's going on I'm just
wondering how do you think our kids are
going to react when they see this dumb
[__] we've done on YouTube and stuff
like that it must be I'm never showing
my child my YouTube channel they're
gonna find it he's gonna find it I'm
deleting that [__] you're the fifth is
gonna find it all right actually oh [__]
yeah it doesn't go down yeah the
accumulation of businesses I'm gonna
break them all going back to the fair
that would be hype as [__] like I start
the lineage at my son being full and
they put so much pressure on the first
yeah yeah he's like all right you have
to deliver so do something crazy you got
you got we got four generations to
figure this [__] out yeah we should go
back I think this is more interesting
we've literally put a timer on it you're
like you better do something [__]
cool yeah first I think it would be
pretty hard though I would be pretty
hyped if I discovered like let's say
Facebook existed back in the time uh
like if I just discovered a long lost
Facebook of my mum when she was like in
University to be like oh this these are
all your drunk photos and uh all the
[__] you're getting up to okay
I think at that point you'd have to like
lock your socials up to a point until
your kids are old enough to be like all
right you you have you have you're ready
to see what your father was with you
ready to see what your father your
father was a mess
I'm a [__] idiot your dad was
probably weird when we get to the point
of social media where there's like
multiple Generations gone by like I'm
doing like 200 years ago yeah you're
like I wonder what they were up to 200
years ago yeah you just see pictures of
people getting smashed 200 years ago at
a school party it's like that's gonna be
so [__] wild you can just tap into
that yeah do you know anything about
like your great grandparents I don't
know [__] great cramping no no nothing
at all I've heard like just like one or
two stories but yeah it would be super
interesting just to see you get to a
point in social media where you can see
what your ancestors got up to to be like
Abby's hype as far that would actually
the family trees will no longer be more
Mysteries all those TV shows about
hunting down the family tree would be so
less interesting yeah we found your
great grandmother on Facebook yeah she
was kind of cringe she posted a review
of the Emoji Movie saying it not bad so
all I don't know how you came to be yeah
uh your granddad was saying some sauce
things on Twitter yeah your granddad was
in q went on um don't worry about with
that Grandad was liking anime ludes like
it's just [__] weird bro it's really
weird I could see uh where you get it in
your bloodline
we've stammed it back do you think
there'll be services in like 100 years
that'll be like hey we can track down
your family tree of social media yeah we
can find your great great granddad's
Facebook yeah maybe unless they just
start deleting it yeah I don't know
that'll be interesting